willkommen bei super easy german wir
sprechen heute über kleidung mit jamie
aus südafrika nikolaus büro und über
kunden aus den usa
jamie trägt heute sehr warme schuhe ihre
schuhe sind schwarz und sie sind innen
gefüttert mit einem fell an den beinen
trägt jamie eine blaue jeans jamie hat
eine schwarze daunenjacke an ist sie war
sehr warm
es ist winter aber jamie hat keine
handschuhe
jamie hat auch keine mütze jamie friert
aber jamie hat einen weißen schal kannst
du einmal die jacke aufmachen
aha unter der jacke trägt jamie noch
eine jacke
es ist eine graue stoffjacke darunter
hat jamie ein t shirt an
darunter hat sie noch einen pullover und
darunter hat sie doch ein t shirt auf
deutsch
nennen wir das 1 zwiebel verpackung eine
zwiebel verpackung hallo nicole nicole
trägt heute im winter sportschuhe oder
auch laufschuhe
darunter trägt sie weiße socken und
darüber eine blaue jeans und
[Musik]
das sind aber sehr lange socken ja hier
ist das eine lange unterhose nicole
gerne nicole trägt eine lange lange
unterhose unter ihrer jeans ist das war
ja ein bisschen war war ich nicht in mir
ist noch kalt im winter trägt man
manchmal lange unterhosen
es ist nützlich nicole hat auch
handschuhe an
es sind dicke handschuhe meine
handschuhe sind denn diese handschuhe
habe ich in einem döner-imbiss gefunden
und aus versehen mitgenommen sie sind
dunkelblau
die colts handschuhe sind schwarz
nicole trägt einen schwarzen mantel eine
lila eine mütze und einen ledernen oder
wein roten schal was trägst du darunter
nicole ich trage ein souvenir aus berlin
nicole hat sich einen pullover in berlin
gekauft
genau hast du noch etwas unter dem
pullover an
ja natürlich
noch ein pullover er ist auch violett
das ist alles das ist alles ist wir
waren nicht so sehr aber es ist besser
als nichts zu haben
super
e book und trägt braune stiefel und sie
hat ihre graue oder schwarze hose in den
stiefeln ist das warm über kunden trägt
eine dunkelgrüne jacke mit einem fell an
der kapuze und sie trägt auch handschuhe
und du hast eine mütze und sie hat einen
blauen schal
außerdem trägt über kunst wunderschöne
rote ohrringe und was hast du noch an
ich habe
etwas ein bisschen lustig ja
hat iveco noch einen pullover an ja aber
meine beine deine arme beine wie heißt
das auf deutsch im contract unter der
jacke noch etwas es ist ein pulswärmer
es ist nur unter dem arm
ok danke dir danke janus friis
altlangsow arschkalt aber er ist heute
eigentlich ganz warm angezogen
schau mal an den füßen trägt schwarze
sportschuhe
darunter hat er sehr populär bei männern
tennissocken außerdem trägt eine jeans
denn sie ist wärmer als eine stoffhose
entscheidend ja sowas hat janosch unter
seiner schwarzen jacke janosch trägt
einen schwarzen pullover
darunter trägt er ein blau kariertes
hemd seine hose wird durch einen gürtel
gehalten und unter dem hemd hat janisch
ein schwarzes t shirt
ja ja zu hause trägt janisch lieber gar
keine hose dort trägt in nur boxershorts
das wollt ihr nicht sehen
außerdem trägt er eine brille ja damit
ich euch gut sehen kann
ciao
[Musik]